grazie
grazie a questa importante introduzione
io mi occupo di venture capital cioè di
investimenti in imprese ad alta
tecnologia imprese innovative
ho iniziato a fare questo nel nel 2002
riporta quegli anni avevo 29 anni allora
non mi sembra di essere invecchiato di
molto almeno così all'apparenza che
dovevo 29 anni e sono stato folgorato
sulla strada del venture capital ha
detto sì mi sembra che possa essere una
cosa interessante come sono andato un pò
intorno riporta quegli anni era appena
scoppiata la bolla delle dot.com un
momento molto difficile per tutto quello
che era innovazione c'era stata la crisi
finanziaria dopo il nine eleven
quindi dopo l'attacco alle torri gemelle
per un momento estremamente estremamente
taf estremamente estremamente duro per
riuscire a fare attività soprattutto di
innovazione in imprese high tech fare
questo in italia è un'altra sfida
indubbiamente norme pro con sono 29 anni
probabilmente è tutto un po più semplice
se prendo anche dei rischi senza farsi
troppe senza farsi troppe domande
un cambio sempre un po di consapevolezza
del rischiare a mettere tutta la mia
carriera tutto il mio futuro tutte le
mie enormi capacità all'interno di un
settore del quale non vedevo forse
perfettamente contorni quindi sempre in
quegli anni ho deciso anche di
diversificare di provare a darmi
comunque una seconda chance un futuro
nel caso in cui l'attività di ventures
non avrebbe non sarebbe riuscito a
portarmi i risultati che mi attendevo
per questa ragione perché tutti questi
dubbi proprio intraprendere un'altra
carriera parallela in contemporanea che
nel caso appunto il vento non fosse
arrivato a quelle statali sarebbe
riuscita a garantirmi un futuro per
questa ragione
per questa ragione iniziato a fare kite
surf e questa foto vado molto orgoglioso
perché è stato uno scatto meraviglioso
che una cara amica fatto forse quasi
irripetibile sono io è quello è non è
uno non c'è photoshop come ho scritto
quindi quello sono esattamente io e
proprio in quegli anni li ho iniziato
questa carriera parallela e se tutto va
male proverò a fare il professionista
come kite border intorno al mondo
spranghe vero delle qualità in direzione
di pisa mal che vada per lo meno mi
diverto
quindi proseguiamo in questa iniziativa
che non è male
torna al ventures quindi ce vò 2002
grandi grandi preoccupazioni grande
perplessità su come potrà essere
potenzialità del sistema italia nel fare
impresa innovativa avevamo già allora
che lo stesso mito che c'è adesso gli
stati uniti stati uniti vuol dire la
silicon valley le mighty il ted no siamo
qui a parlare del terek è una forma
americana quindi dall'altra parte
dell'oceano dall'altra parte
dell'atlantico
in particolare sulla parte pacifica
c'era una in corso era in corso ed è in
corso un enorme una rivoluzione dal
punto di vista delle nuove tecnologie se
nel digitale sia nelle nelle
biotecnologie allora detto proviamo a
misurare questa distanza che separa
l'italia dagli stati uniti perché faccio
vincere capital qui nel mio paese nella
mia country sarà provata misurarla cerca
di darmi dei dati oggettivi a vedere se
stavo facendo la scelta giusta oppure se
ero ancora in una condizione di rischio
di rischio estremo nel sotto vi dà un
punto di riferimento che vuole centrale
in italia siano circa 60 milioni in
america sono poco più di 300 milioni
quindi il rapporto di popolazione una 5
ae noi gli americani producono già un po
di più
quindi il rapporto di pino questa brutta
parola che vuol dire il fatturato che
fanno internazione e di una 8 quindi
sfarzo negher produce più dice
gambardella della grande bellezza ok
quindi abbiamo già un difetto a livello
a livello produttivo a livello di
investimenti invece capita quindi gli
investimenti che vanno a sostenere
imprese innovative
se riuscissimo a mantenere lo stesso
rapporto di popolazione quindi quell'una
5 ci troveremmo un euro investito in
italia che va a sostenere imprese
innovative che corrisponde circa 6
dollari al cambio attuale 6 dollari
rotti negli stati uniti quindi questa
loro chiamata parità aurea no se
avessimo condizioni simili popolazione
contro popolazioni investimenti di
venture capital assortimento a sostegno
di imprese
il rapporto dovrebbe essere questo
quindi questo è dato uno a 240 volt che
negli stati uniti investono i soldi i
capitali che vanno a sostenere le
imprese innovative sono 240 volte
investimenti che noi facciamo in italia
forse era meglio tornare a fare kite
surf e dedicarsi alla carriera
il professionista nel uno sport molto
interessante il pro vivere il mare in
un'altra in un'altra dimensione
quindi indubbiamente questo dato mi ha
molto spaventate mi sono molto
preoccupato
che cosa vuol dire a livello di denari
in italia si fa fatica ad investire ogni
anno non state si parla tantissimo di
innovazione si fa fatica ad investire
100 milioni di euro ogni anno in imprese
innovative in tutti i settori tutte le
start up di cui talmente avete sentito
per parlare se fossimo gli stati uniti
mantenessimo lo stesso rapporto lo
stesso rapporto dovremmo investire 4.5
miliardi di euro ogni anno circa un
terzo della manovra che si sta
discutendo adesso che non ha in
parlamento la finanziaria che si sta
discutendo adesso quindi i rapporti nome
c'è lo spread la differenza
i soldi che ci mancano per riuscire a
essere competitivi come negli stati
uniti sono 4,4 miliardi di euro cioè le
start up italiane soffrono di mancanza
di capitali per 44 miliardi di euro
intorno a dire forse bisognerà fare kite
surf visto che abbiamo delle bellissime
coste delle bellissime spiagge e c'era
molto vento
forse quella può essere può essere la
strada ovviamente non mi sono arreso se
non sarei qui a parlare ma stray su una
spiaggia con divertirmi e sono andato
avanti nella mia analisi uno dei punti
fondamentali che sono andato ad
analizzare è stato il rapporto dei
ricercatori
purtroppo anche qua soffriamo molto per
ogni ricercatore italiano ci sono 25 gli
stati uniti
vi ricordo sempre rapporto corretto
dovrebbe essere una 5 invece in america
sono 25 volte i ricercatori che ci sono
in italia però c'è un unico dato che ci
rende paragonabili agli agli stati uniti
d'america che diciamo il benchmark di
riferimento nel mio nel mio settore un
settore innovativo in generale che sono
le pubblicazioni scientifiche
siamo la seconda potenza continentale
per produzione scientifica
ok nostri ricercatori per quanto non
sono in tanti producono una quantità di
ricerca scientifica di papers sulle
grandi riviste internazionali molto
significativa e competitiva a livello
mondiale
questo è un dato è un dato di partenza
fondamentale per quello che è stata la
mia scelta di abbandonare le spiagge non
completamente solo nei week end di
rimanere invece a lavorare facendo
attività di vincer capital
abbiamo un altro difetto fondamentale
brevettiamo troppo poco quindi il
rapporto brevetti e una 27 qui
nonostante ci sia molta produzione
scientifica non siamo in grado di
trasformare questa produzione
scientifica in brevetti i brevetti sono
il perno centrale per costruire nuove
impresa soprattutto nelle biotecnologie
che è il mio campo che mio campo di
azione di questo è una delle grandi
complessità one billion mindset che un
po alla storia la sessione che stiamo
presentando quindi cosa vuol dire dalla
scienza che è un punto di partenza
solido che noi abbiamo dobbiamo essere
in grado di trasformare questa scienza
in brevetti i brevetti sono la base
fondamentale per riuscire a costruire
impresa intorno ai brevetti intona la
scienza bisogna metterci management e
capacità imprenditoriale poi arriva il
venture capital
ok arrivava in cerca bile che ha bisogno
di tutta quella forza finanziaria che
oggi non abbiamo ancora nel nostro paese
quindi per fare una battuta non
riusciamo a fare start up con solamente
80 euro
la start up 80 euro non può funzionare
fare innovazione essere competitivi a
livello globale di run da reinvestire
molti denari per poi creare impresa
innovativa questo circolo virtuoso può
creare dei casi di successo
qualcuno può dire va bene una bella
storia lo schema è semplice difficile da
fare intanto ci abbiamo fatta nel 2009
con i fondi venture capital che si
chiamava quanti che abbiamo investito in
una società basata a milano che si
occupava di biotecnologie in particolare
di ricerca farmacologica nel campo
oncologico abbia investito nel 2009
quando questa società era una fase di
sperimentazione preclinica abbiamo
portato la nostra medicina al nostro
composto in una fase clinica
abbiamo interessato guarda caso proprio
gli stati uniti proprio l'america e nel
un anno fa nel 2013 abbiamo venduto
questa tecnologia questa questa startup
questa company italiana abbiamo venduto
una società quotata al nasdaq che è il
mercato azionario americano e l'abbiamo
venduta per quasi mezzo miliardo di
dollari realizzando 12 volte
l'investimento iniziale che avevamo
fatto
quindi sì si può fare ci siamo riusciti
questo è un punto fondamentale chi
dimostra che la qualità scientifica che
c'è alla base della nostra tradizione
della nostra cultura riesce a
trasformarsi in in ricchezza in un
valore molto significativo tanto da
interessare quegli stessi stati uniti
che sono arrivati con le loro capre a
comprare la nostra tecnologia
vi posso garantire che per gli americani
venire a comprare hi tech in italia è
una cosa assolutamente challenging anche
per loro da spiegare ai loro ai loro
investitori a loro e al loro mondo
eos non è l'unico caso in italia
nell'ultimo anno e mezzo
nell'ultimo anno e mezzo qui imparo
degli ultimi 18 mesi quindi non parlo né
degli anni sessanta né di una storia
vecchia
nell'ultimo anno e mezzo il bite che
italiano che nelle società ad alta
tecnologia che sviluppano nuovi farmaci
hanno creato complessivamente un valore
superiore ai 10 miliardi di dollari
quindi questo è possibile non solo con
la mia eros ma anche con altre società
che vedete qui all'interno che sono
state o quotate alla in questa slide che
sono state o quotate sul mercato
azionario
oppure sono state comprate da altre
società il valore creato dalla ricerca
made in italy ha generato una ricchezza
superiore a 10 miliardi dollari questo è
l'ultimo anno e mezzo quindi
l'eccellenza ce l'abbiamo
il valore c'abbiamo la ricerca
scientifica c'è dobbiamo uscire
progressivamente a trasformarla in un
valore economico importante visto che
non sono
ho deciso anche perché sono passati un
po di anni di non poter intraprendere la
carriera di professionista del kiteboard
ho continuato a dovuto continuare
seriamente a fare investimenti e
attività o continuate in questo filone e
di raccontar mia ultima avventura che
questa riportata in questa in questo
lucido
abbiamo creato una nuova startup una
nuova o spin off meglio definirlo così
dall'ospedale san raffaele
ci occupiamo di terapia genica terapia
genica per la cura del cancro e questa è
l'ultima sfida del settembre di
quest'anno siamo appena partiti
il nostro obiettivo è creata da kompany
riuscire a sviluppare
tramite questa terapia genica una cura
per il cancro riuscì ad andare in una
fase clinica per la fine del 2016 inizio
di minaccia 17 creare speriamo una nuova
storia che va ad aggiungersi a quelle
che abbiamo indicato prima
insomma in poche parole per arrivare a
conclusione sia katie hoff di vincer
carta si è che fai kitesurf quando fa
l'imprenditore
forse la morale di tutto e cerca di non
tenere troppo i piedi per terra
grazie
grazie pierluigi grazie